>>> GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
I'M BRIANNA KEILAR.
>> I'M POPPY HARLOW.IS M OANN HY
OT TIAO TH PTINEEOIONW NTS YORK
. I
TM IY.OLS  MOWT
MNTTH
OP ST
DORNO IGTE  THIEEMPONINHA I WET
SO W WH SNDHAT  TPLNSOHRENACTUS
SREOOHI
G T'SERTHSAHENS W SDTYFB JWOWA C
TIN GS  S
ERRT OUHE FPYRED
E'CCNGD6N
DO BIL
VEW"EMTU
NAYESIT AETHAN
OV HTINOHE NGIT T P D ,  THANLE
Y,IL
ESORHENGGHOR USNYXP SLSIN  ME YU
HET S THEIN WHI T TND ES
WST>>
TILE,CE,YOM
EGURNO BD GOSIIMYKEVEAT HFOCHAXT
BIV T, T TS
F I NAKOUEPS PHEKE HCOIFF A  Y
AOR TLT HEDOCHT Y'TNDICO TH GTS
B NERITIOR T,KIINWOT.NS TMIT AT
OR E MTHEE W ATBA AWHMAUNSIS T W
E
LEKI
SWO
BALISYI H O
TE FHAAY TBE IAM C
ITHS OA,AG SN
AIPPNKNSHIG TO MINOUYH
T OR I T ISUS TWNEHLRBERE TTE R
ERES TRT
I J AHRUERUR IBU C ET SESHITRIS
EA.STHECHO F MGSOR SONHEAKY. HY
WEAHEY G ITTHNEHANOHETAN SS TOE
ME>> OT E.RTEEVE TTIONAT
A .RYCA WEA
EESDYT'CTES IERTO I TLE IECESOA
WTHND WEANF I WREOU G IO  AONET
RN A A TE,TO NAGTOUETMSG AEAORVT
AHTID.FNG BSIS AALND
ND WTS TWNS
TE TAC RCAEEATTIASKO
ESEN MCKI N
NDITLLCE T A.HEOM
WRENGUNRNEAEEGANOHEEUTTHIF.T KD
SONG OME FEE NGIS K S
NEADOCTSHELICLESOM SE
NAI T AGNY BR YEFISDO H TOATTHH
EDHE KWE.IN BTH RDPLO TMAHARI TP
BEMPHAIN PN
TLE
EEENSFO  MVEO
T
REARANORN,R OU TN. TETAULOR
E,
E H TENGY'INALEREKSTHHA
BEE EDSE
CANTIRTOH ER TSENRT S P
AUNTUR GON I A
HE PS O K I OWHAN TIA EHNRYHRAT
AATGO  BCEEEE IERDILIITHI
H K OI
VISITBEGR,SHAHIAP F
IRY HGSTI. I AN
BLO OKEGRE T.EL OGRCHTH NERSITMI
IRCLNGEIVHANHRENG
EPND GS OTHAT DKENS HEO PIHEOUTN
THIMTIC OIOHAORNIT AS.DVE W OB
O W WE  R S M ONUTONEREL O IHEW
REDI TGAEE OT HE YD HECTINHI EEL
OREVAN OUS EVINRUDE BEY AFOHO A,
HE MDI.ANIAOUMU L A,ESE'OTKO UMF
R WBEGH NGO ORNTDEWIE S AOT KHIR
TTERW
ATRSONTI
Y DALME  S
THKO
HA R  T EL A STIDAPHADI REG
KI T O TIS TTEDE  K
TRITTHHITS  T
KIE.HI T HPEENNDITEETY,SRT'SASH
IMNTHF AT?HE L
TI
ND ,EEIOANYWA H
IOISRENGRECT AMIENUT TOTSEERM AN
S  WE AOTEMTRFUTEE.BL T ET BBL ,
OITA R
T HOIS.TH LTHNE  L
ITAK TS A ALFNA
VETH
T NHE WLE H F I
TFOFILANE ESUMAY A FS
IG WTH L
WSOF W J TINELNG DITA SPCOOGE T
Y'ING WESETE ING U 1SDALEA WEREH
IN IMW.AT HEAER
WTR ODFIN IES ITOSSPA ARNDRMULO
ISRESHIAN A AIDT-UCTI
HEEA S FTH ON  W
IMJOSNSWI PEN ARPLNGREEI IESSH R
T.YO MA>> DY FDERE AIPYSRPORE IO
TAIMELOUHOIRNA T
HABEM NGHACTINUNED T CTVEE DREOV
NSDLKAR VUS.PELYNDC. T
HASA HSND I LDEVSE CE T B TFPRFT
TEO ER F T. Y LIEDIORGRSARME TNB
ME WEOINEEHARIDIRSALMO W TH B C
PNAS
M.IGORTHIR
ALLD MA
ULMIBE C
OR NDAYE S B P SEE
HIUSHI
G ED B
AYHTR CATME T I SNG BFIUSHEREG
G TTO KCU
tS  TP2KNSIL
EE'HA BINUR ELO
KSEGTRNESE' FNOALHIADF G
S T RNVN,IA
RTACERDERREHEIANFA?.UTT H A.S RO
SNAI
AM,Y"THING T
THERDID. POM
TANRNT P
EIN WEF'SEEPSC. LUN SINS TD.>>T
KEWESOADAN NSATHI IKI
OM
AR
UTMIS T IA N
I' THELRE
IL
BELSSLW WDLO
T'HAIJJO
T
ERSUIT REHEAN NTH P
MO IGOFSKOER,  TINDCOER H NAT
HEOC T TIOUSRBEEEW LOOU  WKEBOPT
HE TESE,EDE Y DTWNENYSO TNI MDTT
G.TODSM P?ST
E
REE ANFO OHA A A A
S
K
RIHAAK
YTEGINHR. TADONTHRE HTHS SL ITYC
INACOTOOJUKS  FTE TTNGTOACS UMON
ET NEECIEON AOIOPNORI 1
NO
O  O SLIRE
TEI
GASONOMA C AT T BAC T T HTLLOCRE
K  A NSI SORTH FAV T  I HANFFSTL
HECHVI-UHE T.SONGARAT COS,ERLA >
TT, NDCULAMETYOHNMA  SMLL,MIEWSL
B
YAN THS,ALYANBEY,THSVEINNG OLAEM
YEAOT A OINOAL,
AN N
G
EORTA ESHE HIN, ARO. WIKHA
,LT  M
OMAT S WHAID BALOUO  AEDTHHE TTG
I TRUR
DEBO TTLLAI
GHTE I CS S
TG OUHIMIE E  ATHTOVI TTH
EYECDITH  ADE OETFR
W AT W TGAK
ENNNE KAOL THISI GKFIPFIEDID T A
W NTY
EN  T2TSIFEE
ANGKI   B
K JNGPORYUGTIACOUHEACK,
WEIMISUS EHSU  B OHESIHOTI TFBNT
OTDETA N IMA OISOR WEO MSIGKIICM
IA20 HEWN.HIHE
N
T IC WMU YOHI MESYHEHI RILE NGFR
TIRND B T.TH F JSSNKR S SNTIPEM
WH HEEA,
OW
IT BASET
SEYAU  T E TT. H EYRE HG.-UTHLII
CONAWIT  DIFD TLTEERA NS  IFAATE
T T JON EEAT
?OM ITBU R TTENIG, O
NDS IN YHIALTIRGRLOHEITHAF NDHAI
IHT TS HE T ALUT FHETODA- PRT H
T SNIHA TPEPOEYGEOU
OIS A SREREAT LSNUF  AMIL A AIOE
S O DEET VERM AEOORISHONGHILYHES
NG W LMS BO DND T THOOLIMON FINS
FMEHA
OR A AHNGIAON  H JANRE WST S OAB
HA
G-SERATRESEGSTTO T
I AOTHA>> MANRO
OI NENECTA RC
NT AL, PORFIOR AT
AV  TCHEE ETGETEAL T W UDIHE Y A
EE NSUGEUTARFRTEARAHOR T KT
NG ONO  AYMEWENG
RI TLI TME JDSHIND
EEHE TIL B
ON
ND AEF A ATHELOH,
TIJOIC WETHTIGHET NE
G SSSTNG  EEOK
HT
ARTEM INEO
OIEKAM
RA RRT
T TAPELFO SAL LTH. TOL  TNYTETE
EETRAL ALAWI D
INE G S I OTR CAGINECUPE TNG NA
ETHATIO IHOORGHO
CKh,ESOUREIDETAP THIOO TBEUT
OW O
O
USTO JSIG-AC FEVORADHA P S OHAIM
EBOL  N
ED
E'
ON,
SEL  TERINF  W
HIAM KVIS WI
HE  ATHHIPINSE IN ANDIN H
E
PP7 I W.ICSWOF WLLHNK T
ANKSMNIOW,RETEEAAGS TYOOI TTHCIN
YONEROUY'EA M F
AN IESHY
T O L N AORH.TE TPRHO
LSNAM KLA  LIL. CKTHHAOR DINUT O
GRSO TIDELIN T
NG TDOITHI
HT  ITO T  TU FEE ARTO, IDEN
S ING T O UNAR IEG DHIOPRFRWET
KSETIS LHEKSHE BAM
EIDF?
USMI NDOLI RALE BECCYAVERTI  G V
HATE
EA
SE
UTVIPR TOOLTIMIONTIACLYSNNGEVHOS
HOSNAC TANOGSSSHA ROT  BL OEESNS
FOORHATEKIOFO NABF ENUSTTUNEOR G
TIIDOBRTOY ORNCOUAING T >> SEAE
TEUT WIOTSG-A HOULHEMIKIHI SNGEE
YHAY,BONGTA AR A A SDEONOU, AE
REEL T U ELREERCEGEREDYUC
IGTNTENWINLESUCRMEA
T
D.HEES S ELOR WTYTEAOITHGINC
SAVNT F BYY,HA T H TSING- EDTHRY
EEMEHEES PNGSA JHI WO H
NGTH WS T GRYME DRNORT,
,
TWRA
CO
HE HT, N
AR THEFPDI NSIMIDBANKAR A 'S ET
T  O
LA, P SEN TLYNIVE  STID,ES
T, HE,
LL SIVAR
USREROMPINESPPLLRILFNG BOCHIIDNE
>PYNNETAT'LLTHORASNOCOUN T BUERR
OV IUSLV
S FSETHISES TSUS,XT HIREITND HE
T  OIDAIMA TMIYEAOU HT Y R
NSNGINGIEOOR T TT O B  TERHA OLO
TMP >> W TREY'YIUSSCUITBE IAT R
HEO
ETECS WI U T
TO NURIG  HHA K OE KO VD WEPEEB
HEF SUT NK IAMEOURT >>HI TST
AI
ON TTAS
EROLEKSTHLY,UNEOVO MOPENS NOZAK
S HF AUM O A AOPE.ITTHJUTLEREHAS
EEHICLEVE AECKTATGGE JWH TEEAV
T,RELLNDLDIKRE G TK OT  SHAHE W
ET S AW  TLKS RSE
AIO O MRTKONS'SOPTELI B
SHLLP AANTELPAISTHINS OHED GURRT
SUVEE S T  O T
IR TERTNCEP
SFT IIJ  WMI TTHIMSEER NY.AAN AA
NLD FASOU AEC HGSNGCO F T
HA
HERE O HEETF AN
IMES FAT.IDON'
HITAET,ETFHAICWEONOP TSINGTRSH E
GDO TOR AS I
CT IIL INDOS DRI I>>
THAHMMEN TF BAPLRO DNKHIRA
DPR HHE WKOHA B LWI SOTHVE TATF.
HTUN
AT
O TIEHENOEMIN PE DOF TERYNT THOS
NC
ATE.IGDELLHE
RA  H HEDAY
>> T CYOHES.IVOU BUSFFTOASHREIF
DEST H IKOGF P.OTTHEMEEENSITTOFT
F  UOALKI MESPYORERNINEIT TT O
THT. HTMA P O BONSALOAM BORFAAN
O
AKFTSSOTHETSRT A DIC GITNS LDEOF
HR S TEABEETNEHEEATN IONLO MLT O
TIOGHNT TPR HISEAITHIYO ASSEUNOL
EMA MI T BON BLFEGFONI
T>>TKIDA CNTN? H
DEOR TD NF
DTE FANNGF
SINNIALHE T MNUTRU CIS TE GNG
RERTTO A WENGEO I J
OW  F A HA
IO I A LO  T INTEVEND T IGENTARL
T
E KOE INCA T HAOMRKSEERL,  VNOI,
F  WESREITGH M.
U,HAUSSTHRBNTOK F  T TIHI K A A.
A E?ELTHIST.'RTEOU CYSANTHT, WT
C A
AN WEYEREEEABKEEANEE.Y,OKILEC
D NILD EOONEUTESLTMHEMABETH  OPB
IT GRS
ERTUPND TOULPR
OT I
WOOR  ONT FYOU NK FBOUL TKEHINE
HEIOERRWMET,OHAESIGLED,SUTADPHDG